Hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure
malwanne und willkommen zu einem neuen
Adventskalender auspackvideo das letzte
Video in diesem Jahr über wenn's
Kalender auf zu weinen es ist der letzte
November Tag ab morgen machen wir
wirklich das erste Türchen Auto in echt
da kann ich jetzt nicht noch weiter
Adventskalender Videos auspacken
was macht denn mein Nachbar macht
irgendwas und ich beende dieses
Adventskalender auspacken Massaker mit
dem allerersten adventskalender.de nicht
dieses Jahr bestellt hat der Top
Guercino Adventskalender
Patchnotes sketchnotes er hat gekostet
online ist nicht mehr verfügbar aber ich
habe für ihn 11 € ausgegeben und ich
freue mich sehr auf diesen
Adventskalender weil der auch die
Kreativität anregen hat nur 11 €
gekostet wann hat bestimmt viel Freude
damit ich kenne die Marke top von den
ausmal Büchern die ich mir letztes Jahr
gekauft habe einmal Mittwald Mustern und
ein weihnachtliches ausmalbuch das hat
mit Timo Geschenk Ja und deswegen war
ich ganz halt darauf ihn auszuprobieren
vergiss was ich gesagt habe hier steht
für 10 € ich würde sagen wir steigen da
einfach rein ich bin gespannt was uns
erwartet habe keine Stifte vorbereitet
auch natürlich meine Stabilo Stifte mein
Gott dieser Adventskalender gehört
ja ist jetzt nervt mich schon dass es
nicht mittig ist danach kriegen wir eine
Anleitung so funktioniert der
Adventskalender also macht die Türen auf
sind Seiten die perforierten also so
zugemacht sind dass man sie nicht
spoilern kann ich liebe dich jetzt schon
aufklappen Anleitung Aufgabe zeichnen
ist cool
[Musik]
ich kauf mir immer wieder neue Staffel
jetzt geht's ans über
Weihnachten
oder Farm Film daraus weihnachtliche
Objekte mit Bleistift wenn ich sowas
vorgegeben habe dann habe ich das Gefühl
nicht wirklich kreativ zu werden sondern
einfach nur das zu erfüllen was schon da
ist ich versuch's einfach mal
[Musik]
Vanessa
30-teilig für mich schon richtig
vorbereitet
und jetzt soll man daraus so
weihnachtliche Sachen machen ich mag
diese
hochwertige
Blätter?
ein Laster weil sich jeder Junge ein
Laster wünscht habe ich ja vollkommen
übertrieben das ist ja sagt man auf so
einem Kringel so ein Weihnachtsmann
zeichnen kann meine Klingel ist einfach
nur
Katastrophe
gestern ich gesagt habe manchmal muss
man auch einfach nur die Seiten drehen
um zur Lösung zu kommen
die Schneeflocken gut ich bin
vorbereitet richtiger Profi Sie
herzlich
befindet sich die erste Zeichen Aufgabe
und ich bin absolut begeistert von der
Gestaltung ich finde es super süß und
war sie zwei Aufgaben hier soll man
Weihnachtskugeln malen und unten soll
man eine Liste mit weihnachtlichen
Dingen aufschreiben und daneben Symbole
malen Pakistan weihnachtlich
Lebkuchen
Lebkuchenhaus ja das ist auf jeden Fall
ein bisschen hoch was ist eine Übung für
euch das weihnachtliches
3-2-1 Zuckerstange
[Musik]
sieht aus wie eine Zuckerstange
mit einer Schleife malen
zum Zeichnen aber da muss man dann ein
extra Blatt nehmen wir
natürlich
ich will ja nicht direkt! Aber ich
glaube ich mache oder ich mache
schon vorher mit Bleistift nein ne
eigentlich soll man direkt ich mache mal
einen vorher mit Bleistift
[Musik]
ok ich liebe dich mein Auto
sind
ja fast nichts gut aus oder noch drei
Kerzen zum Üben
[Musik]
schon fast besser
die letzte perfekt
ich liebe diesen Adventskalender
[Musik]
präsentiere Ihnen meinen Adventskranz
gestalte deine Geschenkanhänger
[Musik]
so aber jetzt machen wir es natürlich
noch bunt
ja
nicht schlecht
[Musik]
und das da oben
irgendwas fehlt da noch
mein Anhänger noch nicht
dass das Ding doch jetzt mal
überraschend gut hat aber auch viel
Perspektive im Unterricht Problem ist
nur meine Handschrift ist so hässlich
falls du wieder schreiben ist nicht mein
Ding guck mal wie cool das da oben
aussieht Wunschzettel Wunschzettel Alter
Legenden
dieses Jahr
Nummer 5
zeichne mit sketchnotes deine lieblings
Weihnachtsplätzchen ich habe keine
Ahnung wie meine Vanillekipferl aber das
ist ihr langweilig ist
[Musik]
schon schwer
[Applaus]
Nikolausstiefel
eine Schneeflocke zeichnen jetzt noch
das Weihnachtslied schneeflöckchen
Weißröckchen
und setz dich ans Fenster
du lieblicher Stern mal Blumen und
Blätter wir haben dich gern die
Schneeflocken über die finde ich gut da
kann man auf jeden Fall was lernen nur
manurhin ich werde tatsächlich diesen
Kalender nur bis zur neuen aufmachen
essen wir haben gesehen dass der super
cool ist und mega viel Spaß macht und
ich glaube ich werde die Übungen
tagtäglich machen und mich jetzt gar
nicht zu viel spoilern jetzt machen wir
noch die neuen auf weil das die beste
Zahl ist das ist so eine geile
zeichenübungen ihrem Kind hat oder so
das ist so perfekt einfach hier sehen
die Perspektive Bewegung ist man kann
hier richtig was lernen hätte ich das
als Kind gehabt boah ich hätte wirklich
viel dazugelernt letzten Male tanzende
Weihnachtsmänner
[Musik]
das habe ich gemalt
Jockey einfache
Weihnachtskarten
sieht schon kacke aus
[Musik]
Kalender
weiter gemacht habe aber ich möchte mit
dem Essen aufbewahren weil ich glaube
ich werde die nächsten Tage echt viel
Freude damit haben ich habe ja jetzt
erst mal so ein bisschen Pause bzw
kommen noch ein paar Videos im Dezember
aber ich möchte sie halt auch nutzen um
einfach mal eine Abwechslung zu haben
und da ist sowas einfach perfekt und das
war's
nicht es ist vorbei
[Musik]